le frelon asiatique fait deux à trois
fois la taille d'une abeille européenne
et sa femelle est équipé d'un tard de
près de 6 mm redoutable pour nourrir un
art l'arb les frelons asiatiques sont
capables de décimer toute une colonie
d'abeilles
les apiculteurs sont à l'offensive avec
leurs sous pour noyer ce fameux frelon
là il nous faut de la bière brune
il nous faut du vin blanc et de la
grenadine et puis après vous voyez ce
piège là moi je les vis des il ya deux
jours donc faut que je pense tous les
bijoux vous dire c'est un travail de fou
hein
et ça c'est une femelle fécondée et ça
c'est un hymne moins l'année prochaine
on l'appelle le tigre des abeilles je
pense que c'est pour usurper apparemment
en zone urbaine quand vous avez un livre
trop long comme ça ils s'alimentent à
60% avec de l'abeille domestique
alors je sais pas si vous voyez on nous
dit que un nid à terme c'est un kilo 8 à
2 kilos d'insectes par du lourd de
manger c'est quand même une catastrophe
je dirais pour la biodiversité pour les
apiculteurs le frelon asiatique n'est
que la troisième plaies après le régime
coquio de redoutables pesticides
si les voleuses asiatiques se nourrit
surtout d'abeilles leurs nids peuvent
contenir des centaines d'individus peser
plusieurs kilos et se retrouver dans
votre jardin
en 2012 il ya eu l'arrivée du frelon
asiatique sur le loiret en 2012 j'ai
fait 8 destruction simplement 2013-14
destruction 2014
36 d'être destructions sur l'année hélas
la 41e que je viens de faire pour
l'année 2015
chez des sujets présentant des facteurs
de risque comme l'allergie une piqûre de
frelon asiatique peut entraîner à ne
donne aux provocations choc
anaphylactique c'est à dire une réaction
allergique sévère à l'institut de
recherche sur la biologie de l'insecte
tour des chercheurs mettent au point à
napa phéromones halles à base de sucre
et de protéines contre le frelon
asiatique